Hey, welcome, everybody.
One of the things we're going to spend some
time talking about today are the recent protests
and unrest and violence and the way that people
have been trying to take advantage of that
violence and unrest.
But before we even do that, one of the things
I want to talk about is this broader context
in which Donald Trump is running for president
as if someone else has been president for
the last four years.
And that's just one aspect of what I want
to focus in on today.
And that particular aspect is really unlike
anything we've seen in the modern political
era for presidents running for reelection,
most presidents have run for reelection very
clearly on.
I've been in charge for four years and we're
going to get another four years.
That will be similar to the last four.
And that's good.
Donald Trump is doing something very, very
different.
And that's what I want to talk about.
Now, before we get we get into that, I guess
it's important to mention I'm leaving a lot
out of this analysis in terms of things that
Donald Trump is doing.
Of course, this has been one of the most dishonest
presidencies.
The lie count is off the charts and Donald
Trump has been doing a lot of lying to justify
his reelection as well.
Okay.
On the issues, Donald Trump has failed to
deliver on a bunch of different campaign issues.
The wall replacing the health care system
on and on and on.
But there's a reason that I want to focus
in on this particular aspect, because it relates
to the sort of gas slighty nature of the campaign,
as well as the intellectually compromised
element of Donald Trump's electorate, which
is that Donald Trump is framing his reelection
campaign as if you need to choose him instead
of what we've had for the last four years.
And unfortunately, it's working on a lot of
people, as evidenced by some of the interviews.
When you go to these rallies that Donald Trump
has been doing, the RNC, et cetera.
And the language that Trump is using suggests
somebody else has been in charge for the last
four years.
And in order to fix that, Donald Trump must
be elected.
When you look at this phrase, make America
great again.
Again, that is predicated on the implicit
understanding that Trump won in 2016.
And for a while he was great and he made America
great again.
And then that sort of fell apart, including
with coronavirus and the economy.
And now we need to elect Trump in order to
make America great again.
Again, because it's almost like Trump hasn't
been the one in charge for the last six or
seven months.
We have to put Trump back in power to fix
problems that were actually created during
Donald Trump's presidency, as if he was not
in charge during that time.
This is going to be a big factor in our discussion
about protests and unrest.
Donald Trump has been talking about the mass
protests and the unrest with the framing of
Democrat cities, as he says, run by far left
mayors, anarchists or anarchists, as he calls
them, Marxists and others.
The reality is that it's Trump himself who
has generated the unrest.
We didn't have unrest like this when Joe Biden
was vice president for eight years.
And I'm going to come back to that in a little
bit.
There has been Donald Trump's mishandling
of so many issues.
But Trump is running as if other people have
been in charge for the last six months.
And in order to get things back under control,
you need to elect Donald Trump.
Now, of course, any thinking person would
realize Trump is saying things are out of
control with me as president.
So reelect me to fix it.
But, of course, why would we do that?
Why wouldn't Trump just be able to get things
under control now?
In other words, why is he saying that only
in his second term will he be able to get
these things under control?
And of course, when you realize that he's
been what's been generating the unrest and
the discontent, the entire argument falls
apart in in some sense.
Trump is almost running against himself, but
putting in Joe Biden as a proxy to take the
hit for Donald Trump's own failings.
And I wish it weren't the case.
There's really no way to say this without
offending some people.
But his supporters that are eating it up are
eating it up in great part because they are
intellectually compromised.
Now, some of them know it's B.S., but they
want Trump reelected for other reasons.
And so they're just jumping on the bandwagon.
But a lot of people are actually falling for
this stuff.
Now, there's a few different thoughts about
why Donald Trump is doing this.
One thought is that this is some kind of four
dimensional.
Yes, he's taking credit for successes, but
painting the failings on Joe Biden or on Democratic
mayors or whoever the case may be.
And it's all kind of calculated to paint him
as the underdog despite the fact that he's
the incumbent.
Right.
We could go into some kind of more complex
analysis.
The other explanation is way simpler, which
is Trump's a one trick pony.
He doesn't know how to run as the incumbent.
And he is running the exact same campaign
that he ran as the supposed political outsider
in 2016.
He's just running the same campaign, ignoring
the fact that he's been the president for
four years.
We really have not seen anything like this.
And it's preying upon the most ignorant voters.
But that is not a guarantee that it's going
to fail to work.
It very well could.
It could succeed.
And this is why I've been sounding the alarm
now for several weeks, saying we can't write
off what to many of us seem like obviously
terrible strategies as ineffective because
it may work.
Donald Trump genuinely expects that Americans
are going to fall for this and plenty of Americans
are falling for it.
Now, the other thing on top of this, which
we have to remember, is that Joe Biden was
sort of in charge for eight years, in other
words, when Joe Biden was vice president.
Okay.
Barack Obama was the president, but we didn't
have in Obama and Biden's America chaos and
unrest, the likes of which Donald Trump is
now preemptively assigning to Joe Biden.
Yet you had Tea Partiers who sometimes protested.
You had Ferguson, which was a very different
thing than what we have going on right now.
You certainly had shootings, but that was
a gun problem, which we have not fixed.
But things were actually far more calm during
the era in which Joe Biden was vice president
to the president of the United States.
And so at at even on the facts, you don't
even have to hypothesize what it would be
like if Joe Biden were president.
You can go back and see what things were like
when Joe Biden was vice president.
And we're going to get into later on in the
program.
Why is it that Trump benefits from chaos and
unrest?
You would think that if people were thinking
clearly, they would say, oh, if there's chaos
and unrest while Trump is president, doesn't
make sense to vote for him again, to fix it,
we should vote for someone else.
That would be a logical assessment.
I'm going to explain to you later on in the
program why why that doesn't work.
Or in other words, why does Donald Trump does
benefit from the chaos and why he's trying
to incite it.
But before we go to that, let's talk about
the after effects of the Republican National
Convention